[Music]
what happening [__] greetings
welcome to the Church of what's happened
now I'm your host Joey Diaz aka mad
flavor my main man
Lili syat is in the [__] house
little doors came in who do you love
somebody made that song he's laying it
was alright the [__] guy you know to
bourbon two shots on one bill gives a
[__] are you doing today Lili Weiland
I'm doing a fantastic man listen show
yesterday was great Patriots when I'm
happy but I just told you not to [__]
and talk about football that's the first
[__] thing you did I you did not talk
about yeah not the football anyway the
beautiful [__] day to realize because
not that's what it turns into
okay anyway it's a beautiful [__] day
to be alive we did it we made it to
Monday hit him with a little [__] now
I want to be around by Tony Bennett
[__] thing I said
[Music]
that's only better I want to be around I
want to be around Tony Bennett then when
I told you to line up with the bridge I
wanna be around we all right tonight
yeah to pick up the multimers when
somebody a freak there you go baby will
Tony been against the day my mother used
to play this every Monday every [__]
day is the first Jam she put on so I do
lot of respect you [__]
so Lee you [__] it up already with the
football so he might as well talk about
it New England want everybody [__]
one except I had to under than in
something cover turn lovely they didn't
cover those [__] they were
winning with two minutes talking about
but that's what gambling is about that's
why there's 17 weeks
you lose one but it's not like you lose
I lost 55 [__] thousand dollars we
are going to be 24 lays and two cheeses
in it who gives a [__] that one game
blasted you got 17 weeks you go 14 and
311 net losses of about 100 a week
that's $1100 enough with that [__]
already who gives a [__] there's two
games on tonight if you want to be a
degenerate dope Benham I wouldn't [__]
with him there's two games tonight to
rip your [__] heart out so you got to
go to homeless and your kids just went
back to school and now you got to pay
the [__] bookie back to school Rick
till God knows one but anyway that's
over would you watch last night TV there
was dick on TV last night there ain't
dick on my watch I caught up on the
movies do you watch them at all
sometimes it was it was [__] amazing
this is done and I know everyone says it
so it's kind of hacking the tailor who's
amazing but it is I watched I watched
the bat last two episode and it was just
one of him losing his kid in New York
and it was just like he was terrified it
wasn't it wasn't that it wasn't funny
but it's just the fact that he's doing
on TV was great so that I caught off on
that and that's about anything other
than that they're constantly breaking
bad little dose nothing nothing I mean
it's a Sunday so I watched something on
20/20
60 minutes about the soldier kills Obama
bin Laden when they got out there I
watched that until I could tolerate the
[__] [__] I couldn't tolerate
that no more
I worked out yesterday nice little
[__] workout I ran around I've been
working a lot more legs I'm going up to
five days a week today I'm gonna go to
[__] yoga I go to one-hour yoga on
Wednesdays a quick beginning tight yoga
[__] I've been going there for a while
get that over I got an audition in town
that's it that's my [__] Monday
Wednesday or Thursday I go to
Minneapolis well you [__] up
there close to that Mall of America I
can't work I can't believe they hide me
at a [__] Mall of America yes I'm
gonna be walking around there I heard
they got police dogs oh yeah that whole
show that talk about how bad TV is but a
year ago they had a whole reality show
of us and police-court
in all America and it's [__] stupid
cuz they're learning run don't what you
can't wear hoodies there and it's like
if it means this [__] [__] you have
to bring the camera you know are you
gonna get you're gonna get yelled at I
used to go to Minnesota all the time I
sang on Mankato where the [__]
Vikings practice when they just bring
training whatever the [__] it is well
that first moved to Colorado ladies
threw out a bunch of friends from
Mankato who were [__] crazy these
guys were all dead doubles they jumped
off all this [__] that these people do
now with the bicycles they jump off with
you know johnny Knoxville and his
buddies there these [__] are
doing that one night one of the guys got
cheated on by the girlfriend uh-huh and
I seen him he was this lanky skinny
[__] I loved them in Colorado he
drove a bus for the whitewater rafting
people yes and I said what he had
because I'm a [__] guy I go don't be
careful up here this [__] hid
under the car his under a car and waited
for her and the boyfriend the guy she
was dating to come [__] grab the guy
by the ankle [__] that [__]
came it's classic stories of that man
Cato people I love that know if you
remember me anymore that was like
nineteen of them we were all friends and
landed up all my only 40,000 to blow
grunting these [__] ones and but it
was funny because when I [__] came
back asked me to visit years ago I
bumped into him I said I go to $40,000
let's ask the Navy seven or like sixty
thousand dollars forty thousand just to
him and I go back like in 95 uh-huh
and that's the first [__] I bump
into the day of the forty Tennessee have
a comment
but he didn't say nothing to of course I
said where you been - he didn't even say
he [__] knew he was never gonna see
that [__] paper again so it really
didn't matter all [__] I got the leash
of [__] Michaels in the house
and [__] he came over she brought some
oatmeal I hope I'm [__] starving
fruit that's even better I had a bunch
of fruit last night I'm [__] let me tell
you I'm bout the shtick if you smile off
lightly it's not even farthest because I
[__] my [__] pants cuz that night I
ate a lot of fruit you know I like to
eat a bunch of fruit before I go to bed
yeah that's last night like a [__]
whole cantaloupe farm [__] swear to
God I had a whole cantaloupe farm I even
found like a mexican hand in the [__]
back yeah I ate that too I mean it's uh
it was [__] amazing but now I gotta
go to the bathroom you came too early
usually I don't take the dump of the
morning till about 10 after 8:00 when my
wife is getting ready to leave I got a
call a timeout and go dog I gotta go to
[__] bathroom yeah and here it is but
one thing I did want to talk about today
cuz it you know it's always [__]
bothered me and they were really talked
about it bothered me that much that's it
I don't even talk about it that's it
we're going on and [__] into the 11th
anniversary of 12 in 911 tomorrow and
yeah we all holy [__] I didn't even
think about it yeah nobody's 11:11
[__] years you know and last night
they did have a thing on discovery or
John dotnet geo one of those [__]
channel and that's how important it is
no one even watching it it's not even
about voices from the sky of 911 the
people who work Wallman and saying it
sold for these [__] a rap step open
up unexplained what are we going to do
they had I don't know what the [__]
going on I listened to that for about
six minutes and I don't know when either
people were having conversations it
didn't matter
I started crying just [__] sitting
there like a moment I don't like got to
do it whenever there's something about
dead people on the news I can't I can't
do it man it's weird
and I sat there and I was thinking about
all these [__] people that just went
out there was my three shows they've
been playing them all [__] weekend
there was one guy hitting a D on Twitter
didn't talk about Tower two that I
talked about [__] nothin I got a the
truth you stupid [__] where am i
watching this him get the [__] up he was
sitting there all sucking down Sunday
watching 9/11 [__] getting tormented
with this [__] is to put on a [__]
football game but he kept
and you're lying then I thought who
gives a [__] they're not gonna tell you
the [__] truth and while in that
[__] geo cops knock knock what the
[__] is wrong with people he's sitting
for the TV they want they think I gotta
tell them what they wanna hear
even if they think it's a lie I get the
same way sometimes so sit down listen to
this show you know it was there was a
show they were talking about that this
lady with a husband called it from the
plan he had two little girls a four
month old girl and ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
and I'm sitting it but I'm getting
[__] he hit me
sure they were talking to people who
were running away when the towers fell
and they were saying that uh chambers
and Broadway had become [__] cloud of
smoke and that's when it got my stomach
because chambers and Broadway let me
[__] times I walked on that thing was
changes whatever the [__] streets
they were saying how many times I walked
around on them in when I first I
remember the morning when it happened
I was sleeping and my wife you know miss
worry was in Tennessee is like oh my god
oh my god oh my god I swear to [__]
god the giant had lost a day earlier
uh-huh it was that and uh it was the
week of Barry Bonds who's going to chase
the home run Tyler huh and I kept
hearing Paul Mooney in my head going
they're gonna do something that Negro
and they're gonna get some home run
they're gonna do something and I'm never
forget when they said the World Trade
Center got [__] bomb I told about two
things they either thought about
something he got pissed about the Giants
losing or I mean this is you know I
didn't know like that's where your mind
for visual my mind went or [__] look
at that Paul Mooney was right they did
bomb the building so Barry Bonds oh he's
about formerly the command always talked
about you yeah black people and [__]
they did I mean I swear to god this is
what I thought I go they big bomb the
[__] thing that's why they're not
going to give the record house plenty of
it and then you know wasn't even funny I
heard what happened the plane the second
plane and so that like me I felt cheated
I'll tell you why because when I came
from Cuba that's why
to New York City you know one thing
about me go I don't know much about
Brooklyn alone or Syosset I've been up
there to get drugs that's all I know but
the five boroughs I only had drugs and
pizza I've been to Brooklyn to get drugs
and pizza I've been to the Bronx with my
parents kind of dry cleaning up that I
went later on to get drugs and pizza
long I went up there to see concerts but
Manhattan as far as Manhattan's concern
I know like the back of my [__] hand
from 178 all the way down the fourth
Street with Boston Comedy Club is to you
know mix all these air house you know
from [__] that was what people
understand where I grew up in Hudson
County Jersey New York City was my
[__] playground
yeah it was my playground I went to New
York to [__] play if I play hooky New
York if I get a fake ID New York if I
want to go to something uh-uh what we
called peep show where you [__] look
at people having sex in a circle you can
went to New York it was my own private
[__] nun with my own private
playground I know every avenue I know
every nook and [__] cranny when I
left New York in 85 I knew every [__]
nook and cranny and even more important
than that you you grew up in North
Bergen but either when you came from
Cuba you were living in Manhattan
Manhattan and I know that that's I can
view in New York I mean I have a buddy
Mike a squeeze he was in the 31st floor
that circle building on the Jersey side
that you always be and he said he was
having quality and breakfast yes
consider himself though he goes dog that
plane was [__] flying low at least on
the plane yeah he saw the whole thing he
was new this year and backyard watching
the news and also he said that to
himself that plane was [__] flying
low but that [__] doesn't matter it's
just uh the pain like it causes me the
anxiety because I don't think about it
it's like when a girlfriend cheats on
you and you're out having a great time
or something bad happens you don't think
about it you know that's how bad it is
for me like I don't think about it
that's my [__] steady man you know
and I always said that I listen let's be
a homicide I'm not one of those [__]
New Yorkers at Ciccio which is no good
[__] food or peace I don't give a
plop I've been out of New York so long
way beyond that level let's be honest
with each other when [__] New York
sneezes everybody catches a call
yeah that's where it all goes [__]
down you know that's why I want to hit
that I mean they knew exactly they
[__] hick there they [__] hick
there they didn't give a [__] they went
there and it was like what the hell they
were doing so uh it just bothers me it
bothers me to no [__] end I just
don't digest it yeah I don't want to
[__] digest I was in the city when
they first I was walking around when
they first [__] blew up the wall or
in the 1994 I was ten blocks away I was
on a pager my pager wouldn't work was
Friday my buddies are trying to beat me
to get him blow cuz that's what I would
do I would get them blown to say when I
come over the bridge I charging me
connection 20 bucks they're all peeping
me you couldn't get the [__] pages
and those guys had the little office out
of Jersey City but the weirdest thing I
heard about 9/11 that really listen guys
there's always going to be a [__]
theory and there's always going to be a
conspiracy and some of us live our life
through that some of us don't I live in
the middle but this is what I did here
by Jersey City
you could catch the thing you know
they're not the shuttle but the ferry
from Jersey City over to new New Jersey
and from New Jersey over to New York
City and the [__] funny thing is that
there's a hotdog man there and the
hotdog man they said it gets to 20 below
and that [__] always been he's
from one of the nation I don't know I'm
not to break all that stuff time so I am
state racially intensive so work with me
he was from one of the countries over
there he was selling hot dogs
grilling [__] out there and every
[__] day come rain sleet snow the guy
was out there today they blew up the
towers he was not that so the word on
the street said that all those there's a
big Arab community in Jersey City and
attract the FBI found two copies
supposedly they had made copies and pass
them around that area not going to not
go into the city aside I don't know if
this is true and he always had but I
heard it from a reliable source my spine
works for public service and he's there
every days working for 30 [__] years
of my friend's father yeah and this is
what he what he had seen that was [__]
with him that they never reported that
stuff he was I still remember the people
coming over
from the from the [__] shuttle and
they were walking off off the ferry and
people were you know hitting them with
water or the chemicals to take that dust
off obvious I couldn't forget how
[__] sad it was you know what time is
it this definitely should be called
today yeah in 10 minute Devon is my old
[__] girlfriend that I moved to
Seattle with no totally gonna grow in
podcast to bother us you know stay what
you want to say man she stripped three
years she still dances I mean she's
crazy she's got two kids but was the
power I wouldn't be here because you
know I was making money in Seattle but
not the money to [__] move here and
finance a trip or even finance me I was
making barely eight hundred a month in
Seattle's a [__] comedian and she
[__] finance the rest so we did have
problems here and there and the
relationship I can never forget what you
did I'm not that type of when somebody
takes Cammie
I remember them for [__] ever let's
see what we got I'm the prescription
barrel today [__] let's deal we got
all this that topic yesterday of all in
things I went to the [__] why did you
just hit with my shirt my wife said oh
yeah you got the shirt was still wet
from yesterday when you go to Y on a
[__] I tell you I don't [__] around
guys I don't know why on unedible it's
not gonna work it out yesterday I did
thirty five minutes on the bike dirty on
the bag and then I ran the [__] I did
the Dolce if you guys really want to get
your life together and you really want
to change in nutrition you're sick and
tired of being a fat [__] I mean I
always be a flat [__] it's in my [__]
genes you know I'm saying
but if he's ticking tired of being a fat
[__] go get the to Dolce books we threw
him realistic I'm not gonna lie to you
guys think I'm here sucking making that
stuff all the time I'm not he's got a
lot of kale a lot of green stuff in
there he's got a breakfast bowl that you
might like he's got a lot of stuff me
I'm a picky little [__] [__] when it
comes to food super bags in the
[__] house you see super best
he hurts your little [__] things you
see him he's no [__] good you know
what I don't even have his treats but I
don't know what the hell happened to
Terry
yeah he could come in he's a man of
[__] steel he could do with the he'll
be one but here's what we got today we
got they ready for this [__]
peanut brittle oh okay this is peanut
brittle that [__] your world up I got a
workout this morning by 11:00 this is
when I go to yoga eat one of these and
they also gave me stuff at that time the
new you reek of vapor
this is master [__] cush indica
people always say meet you looks just
like you smoke in the daytime it's
called do you reek of a I'm trying to
save my lungs a little bit that bone I
smoked birthdays for you guys optical
illusion arrested down low smoke brief i
smoke the vapor you press his
[__] like this one two three
four five the light blink like a [__]
Batman signal you pop it again and there
you go living like Bob Marley before the
[__] bad hairdo all right
hahaha Felicia who you texting already
at 7:00 the [__] weasel messing
Instagram up un-fuckin'-believable
un-fuckin'-believable justice and this
is picking [__] I don't know what
happened yesterday I got outside yes you
know we played some music people been
bugging me all [__] day where's
yesterday's podcast I don't know we put
it up on iTunes go to iTunes by the way
from the bottom of my [__] heart I
mean this directly when I started this
when we start the podcast Felicia we
never knew we never [__] knew and
that's my witness we just show up every
[__] week do a podcast and you
[__] do what you do so thank
you thank you for giving us the love
thank you for putting us on that [__]
charge least I asked the flying [__]
Jew I came in here talking about knowing
he loves nothing New England Patriots
and me and I you don't got to die me
just sit there like I sold you if they
lose he knows the moves equality I know
nothing I look at the line I think
they're gonna play next week and I see
what the [__] weather is up and
that's it Sunday
yeah get terrible maybe she is only
gonna she is you can get some catnip
swarming money I'll tell ya a sticker we
took down yesterday's video right
recently so uh I don't know if someone
complained or or just some guy walking
it but uh they took it down and but it's
up on iTunes uncensored and we're number
five when I couldn't show it
unbelievable
what's [__] blown away all we're
doing here is two little chubby [__]
talking about you people want to make
his number five and here's the [__] up
thing thank you my love is the [__] up
date I call these [__] on these
green buds Pettit buds think something
discontinued the farmer had a heart
attack or some [__] so there's no more
bud try the koalas on open that door for
me and get the get there open that door
for me go and get the cut with left
what's that I need everyone they can
yeah get them in here I want it I want
them to see the [__] cabinet buttons
Monday Harry come it's October come to
feed ow stop being a little cops 11 come
infidel say hello you can little fee
delete so it sounds like what the [__]
is going on I love my cats guys and you
got to give them these things because
when they're you give them the catnip
look at these look at these bugs these
are like [__] leap above them they
show up like a [__] look at grey
show up please at least oh shut up and
you give them some catnip and I'll tell
you I don't know what sin is supposedly
girls don't react the catnip as much as
boys react to captain because it's the
same chemical into the [__] in their
piss really in the girls pit that's why
they lose their [__] mom I don't
smell no fish I just smell like a reefer
cause it smells like well listen man if
I leave this here one night and I have a
couple cocktails yeah I know why but
look I leave this on the [__] table
here I'm gonna smoke this by mistake I'm
surprised you already have it come in
without come in come in right away come
in bring me well [__] like a puppy's
[__] cat inside you shipped it and
then these [__] don't show up
you try to be a [__] nice guy but
that's it was 9/11 I didn't want to
depress people it's [__] Monday cops
up and get your [__] together as we call
it
namaste [__] let's do this let's
get some peanut brittle in it
and that's not waiting for the dirty
[__] filthy animal of course she's
calling it you go now it'll be in three
minutes not even nice girl she's a
[__] you know you know she's got
something inspired at time I guess she's
lived in Florida it's Cocteau their
humility makes it go to your [__]
brain
you know I'm CUBAN everybody always just
me how was it growing up in Miami with
it look at this day the peanut brittle
is green did you see that
it's [__] green it's like uh it's
like uh what do you call that [__] uh
what's that [__] stuff the one people
I take what Linda Blair puked in The
Exorcist that's what it looks like now
is that what you suppose I'll cut that
that half as much most people you eat
like what Ricky wasn't because it's a
breakfast to the last if don't shake die
to prove it how many pulling on the
animals is that about three fabulous
that's the way watches will be having in
five years on the point thank you for
bringing that up
wait barking if you're listening get the
point system on you Adam oh stop stop
I've got a book I got
they give you a book on charge all the
pointing [__] permutation them we want
you to please slick operation they
banging out every month by pay if you
really want to lose weight go down at
like this point system I use your to
scoop lady fruit they should say nah
it's rude you gotta tell some point go
[__] yourself is fruitier pisses out in
[__] ten minutes I wasn't gonna be
pointing him and now they don't try to
put point so I was ahead of my time
because I did the [__] program when
it were charged the two three [__] some
points so true apples and share how to
make Church point but that doesn't make
sense to do you want kind of want to
lose weight you you want to lose weight
because you haven't been eating fruit is
they're going to start charging points
for fruit they should be like eat as
much food and vegetables as you want
I guess boot turns into sugar okay so
but still it's like you're walking
around if you're [__] if you're
moving up you're sweating that thing
should go right through it better than
have any candy bar well that's my option
you know sometimes you get in the
kitchen one night this is oatmeal
[__] ball with cream in it or you
could have two apples yeah you know the
motto is maybe not hungry for a [__]
Apple then [__] you a [__] hungry
you follow insane and it's true but I
actually I I saw this last night and
Natalie brought it up Oreo is releasing
candy corn
Oreos would you like the most disgusting
even as a bad guy my dad listen bro Oreo
look I got fat later on in my [__]
life after like 30 but I the fat gene
was written because I'll have to [__]
eat so I knew eventually I was gonna
start looking like I'm like a little
bottle I always [__] knew that they
took the fat out of everything people
nothing tastes the same oh yeah nothing
tastes the same when you a kid you see
some on the [__] show you get excited
you go [__] get it and you bring it
home you dip it in milk and it's not the
[__] same they took the fat out of
[__] Oreo it's just the fat out of
[__] no Chips Ahoy they justified out
of everything well that even just a fat
a little cracker they give you at church
everything tastes like dick now now
they're trying to [__] charge you in
New York I've been seen this for a year
I don't know why just let them know the
rules literally want to charge more for
sodas yeah they want to put a soda tax I
paid $100 a gram of coke your name how
is an extra 50 cents gonna stop a fat
[__] drinking soda it's the same
thing we paid in the $1.00 for the
[__] grammar bulletin to turn off but
if I'm doing blow people lost their
wives their lives they lost everything
you think putting the tax of 50 cents on
a stop that [__] drinking show
different act on and they're limiting
the side to like 16 ounces which is
idiotic
so what are we gonna do it was my forum
by for them or you could just keep
what's down 11 on every [__] corner
yeah she just walk the forest it's the
dumbest thing the [__] [__] we [__]
and focus on give these kids a lot van
and and I [__] bomb that's what you
do you stick a bomb to a [__] lap
band no more [__] going over a
certain range week two or three more
[__] doughnuts
you don't even the last man don't blow
up you [__] ball like a terrorist
[__] that's it put us up this triggers
an eight on a lot man y'all make
[__] start being skinny because
it think about a diet is listen I'm a
fat [__] you plus I get high I love to
suck at me you know what man we do what
we do but we know how to lose the weight
we know what we need to do people walk
around the country like ah I can't lose
the way you know what you [__] need
to do and you need to push yourself away
from the table you [__] filthy
[__] animals I'm the fat [__] so
don't come to me
no [__] story that's number two and
number two you gotta [__] move around
a little bit but because months when I
first started losing weight
I ate what the [__] I wanted to men talk
because I would box and run and get
chased by [__] cops
directly which it did that diet is so
[__] important like right now I hate
drinking soda pop like not that it's not
diet like I drink a diet soda if I'm
gonna rush after leashes would
appreciate looking good til you got your
little [__] heavy-metal outfit on
well you got a Savin this weekend
looking like she's going we got your
call Simon she's looking like she's
going to a Whitesnake concert
what's the story beautiful hey Joey
local hey you sexy [__] and I what's
happening you called it give us whole
damn Thursday and I can go in you drop
the kids at school yeah yeah then I'll
explain at Florida lately I'm so scared
they're gonna call and say we're taking
the day off again I'm gonna lose my mind
oh you had two days off for the
hurricane and [__] we got it oh I didn't
know hurricanes like nothing there was
I'm fully week we didn't get that much
at all and they let my kids out of
school I'm going to deal with all that
everything when this platters on Monday
they're back in school when I go rocking
with my girlfriend get some Sun you
gonna put some [__] coloring that
real monkey
I'm happy you [__] caused a because
I've been doing these podcasts for two
years and I always tell [__] funny
stories about you and I was telling them
that we were together for a while and we
and I but I love him we had a lot of
problems but if it wasn't for you I
wouldn't be here so that's why we're
still friends and that's why I thank you
and I love you all my heart you know
we've always kept in touch with each
other and but I've been telling crazy
[__] stories I always tell them to
sexy [__] stories but the story I
told them that they liked it hanging
went for that [__] thing in Seattle
that little like river and you had a
bikini island with like Assam and I took
the wine cooler and I started rubbing
your little [__] monkey with it and
then I started putting it in your
[__] monkey and all sudden your
little piri
with their story shot backwards in the
bottle I painted tell these
[__]
I like oh god it's hot oh [__] he's not
even over ever I was exactly Robin
Holly or even for out I've never see
anything like that that's [__]
hilarious yeah oh my gosh light and you
tie like your oh you fell and I we went
out of the back we went to other parts
that time Gas Works where Pearl Jam used
to play remember we used to go to Gas
Works and have barbecuing one in the
water and I cut something I think the
dead to one half I was a regular [__]
faint machine yes you are
I was hand on the bloody everyone I love
it I always tell these [__]
about our sexy [__] escapades when I
used to smack you in the ass and choke
you and smack you in the face and you
love her the [__] I remember one New
Year's I smack you so many times in the
head you had two black eyes and [__] we
were [__] we got so excited those are
the good old days
ha ha ha it's like it so hard to face my
ribs are bruised oh [__] yeah anyway
yeah you're the sexiest freak I a
freakiest guy I've ever been I'm sorry
yeah I'll be for you guys thank you yeah
you were definitely you take the heat
oh please you know I love to use is
possibly you remember what I said I
remember it fondly I was thinking fine a
guy's freaking you oh please actually
you've asked and I get the [__] come
come juice out of your monkey I don't
[__] around
I love all that [__] but that's when I
was a young man now I can't do that [__]
no more if I go to eat yeah after all my
[__] backup I want I don't think you
asked me why you answer you don't know
what in too long if I could what I don't
know it's not ass anyways Sims along if
I can do what they like in my ass hey my
search bubble Falls you would cost oh
you filthy [__] don't make me come on
your neck you know
hey let me ask you something a couple
weeks
you called me because you're still dad
from time to time correct and you were
telling me you told me possibly one of
the funniest things I have ever heard in
my life and usually when used to call me
and tell me something funny the first
but only person I would tell is Josh
wolf because he owns the other one that
understood you but a couple weeks ago
you were telling me that you had
arthritis in your wrist why do you have
arthritis in your wrist yeah yeah that's
it got together I raised my wrist in
lines very hand because the club I work
in Tampa is very risque and the end that
pretty much even [__] and I was like
you know John is still have not yet
my hand is getting TMJ or whatever it is
arthritis in my hand I could get kicked
out thank you
given too many plans I'm hey you got to
go on steroids I'll be like one of those
exotic dancers on your press positive to
steroids and that's you you won't get
her if they come on your tits will
bounce off I hit them in the face
you don't play that's right oh my god
yeah no it's up I was six when we're
going to get some Republican and
national events and people from RNC
people this past week didn't come in
don't get me animal stompy we have a
donkey
so there's incoming Republicans like
yeah Republicans were the Florida
contingency was right by our club and an
expert at the Golf Resort their holiday
book so I think entire team is very
tactful a while they weren't they
weren't tall enough to see where they
were throwing some money around and that
refutable floor and they said everything
is booked
so it's your two together but they don't
sell itself I do see we're trying to get
naughty their time to get me to come
back there will at all what are we doing
here yeah you said this time bought the
arthritis if you're talking about the
arthritis you can only give handjobs at
left hands
yeah our eye left-handed I have to be
ambidextrous project sir now you gotta
learn how to give hand jobs with your
plan I had a buddy in high school at
love when women used to give my hand job
with his foot with their feet so you
have to learn how to use your feet and
give a hand job I think you stuck at all
if I asked one time so you're in the
game you got you know it's cracking
yep this guy when we wear silk stockings
and wrap my feet on his socks that I did
at Macau whoops
I was it I thought well I'm pretty good
at that I got it more often
you're a sexy [__] he was good
at all that stuff you really should
write a book the years I couldn't find
another woman yeah what I just rip the
tail but he says the tail from a
stripper some tales of whatever I never
got the title or not marry you his tales
I was [__] filthy [__] monkey
that's an area book tales of a [__]
up don't be savage animal would you
still you put these out like one two
five I know
tales of a naughty super [__] to
savage and flora I love you that with
all my [__] heart time have you
called them today you know I don't I
have my problem I don't have everybody
calling I have my dear dear friends
calling on this I've only done five
before shows and I've only had my
friends from Jersey and I think the
world of you
and even though I used to put a bottle
in your monkey even Tom looks like
aluminum cool yeah call I still love you
[__]
have a great week and stay beautiful and
say black
alright bye mama alright that's the last
of the real deal guys that woman is 47
years old she still strips
she's got two kids and she won't take
[__] from nobody
she got so you don't collect this just
got her master's degree here and a
master's degree about him I need some
thinking I was about 80 years old and
she sucked his death out she died and
left only three million
oh [__] way before my car mm - okay and
she remarries another guy and he went
over a cop on a coke binge knocks over a
cop a cop in my hand and my Achilles
heel Jesus comfortability go stop stop
boom ha ha ha ha and he's walking left
the country to Greece feel after some
money
Wow he took that and she bought a bunch
of gems those curves well I'm a little
[__] Punk huh yeah people like
stripping it has a negative connotation
in this country but like a plain Felicia
that just wanted women mm-hmm they know
they know how to run their life young
woman you're confusing your dumb [__]
you need some [__] direction I'll go
to slip for a year ha ha ha I mean
you've got the suck some dick and losing
that number he's learned we've learned
about human nature no you really do so
she sold the gyms okay before they hit
rock bottom I think that curves is our
business I guess of course made money on
that feels like eight rental properties
in Florida yeah chicken and she's single
she does where the [__] she wants yeah
just did you dropping her kids out of
course you can go to the beach you know
what 20 years ago everybody would have
called her a [__] whatever she does
what her duck she does three kids we
heard out ups and downs last time I seen
her well time when we broke up we were
on Sunset and Gardner mm-hmm she had
mace in her hand and I had a steak so I
had just bought our pork loin I was
gonna hit it with the Portland haha we
want sunshine
what Sunset Boulevard she's like the
busiest Street in Hollywood on a [__]
Sunday we were on Sunset and Gardner we
were in the car she hadn't made and I
was gonna hit about my pluck and kill
you I'm like that caught myself when I
go it's always
we can't date no more we can't be
together this happens all the time we're
together for five years this happens all
the time we get into [__] brawl out
yeah she got down she grew up with nine
brothers she didn't give a lot she put
you with you really hit her with his
date I was gonna hit it with the buffers
and I'm a [__] head you know me I
don't give a [__] and you take it out of
the package no no they go around you
know if anybody knows that like Gardner
is just three blocks around yeah just
come from shopping and we got into an
argument the car about something we only
went three blocks and she's like [__]
you [__] you [__] one time we
got until fine shipped up my check in
Sodom she ripped up a check I grabbed
her by the [__] hair in the car and I
pulled so hard you're not like she was
driving first time I wasn't allowed to
hang out with her we had restraining
orders against each other only I'm in
the backseat driving around like [__]
not that kidding uh you know like like
somebody's looking for me I'm in the
backseat like I got a warrant and she's
driving I go over I give it a check and
she goes this is my check [__]
you only from shot my mother I go I need
guys [__] money she's like you're not
getting it in fact I'm dropping you all
I didn't know what to do I just tug the
head cuz she'll always pull my [__]
handle really remover here you
[__] I did that check and she's
like oh right she turned around just
started smacking me well I miss driving
while she Drive we pull over some
[__] lady's pieces and call the cops
now I gotta go on a [__] tear I got
to go hide I'm running through the
streets to see how this happened at 2:00
in the afternoon Josh wolf was in my
room at the time he was leaving that day
holy SH he was leaving for LA that day
okay I was going to meet him two or
three weeks later so that afternoon we
get into this [__] argument the
[__] car I pull ahead some lady
season calls the cops the cops are
looking for me all over [__] stay out
I decide to hide in the garbage dumpster
by the Tropicana or something
restaurants from the tornado or
something it was downtown there was a
movie theater I'd seen Pulp Fiction
there okay so I'm sitting in this
[__] garbage thing for two hours and
I'm like Who am I gonna call there was
this big big black guy his name was Rico
with a spider on his face it was good
friends of Mitch Hedberg he had a spider
[__] tattoo on his face
with a lot of out of his own beard not
even a tattoo like the guy he went to
will put a requires a lot of figured out
of a beard
oh he always told me he was a gangster
he was a gangster he was a gangster so I
go into this [__] restaurant like all
[__] week when I go Rico I had a
problem with Devon come get me
he's driving around I want eyes in a
[__] dumpster with flies [__] I
mean it's phenomenal dumpster behind a
restroom now why did you hide in a dump
them I'm gonna sit in [__] plain
sight and wait for the cops to come get
me no but you called the cops they
didn't know who you were
it doesn't matter they knew who the [__]
I was it has a description I'm sure you
always got a hide so I couldn't sit in
the restaurant because they were gone
from restaurant I mean really Seattle
police got nothing applause okay Seattle
please young Seattle has a [__] thing
that if you got arrested you got 72
hours and so they can press [__]
charges the biggest restaurant of Friday
you gotta sit down to a Monday you drop
charges Seattle's a [__] communist
clapping state people always give me
when you coming back to Seattle
oh never that's why I got [__]
warrants up there I can't go to Portland
I can go to Idaho so don't let some guy
yes asked me yesterday what I'm gonna do
a concert in Montana this Billings have
a [__] Airport yet because I want
Isis to call me you know being from
Colorado that's what you do you do
Connie and [__] Riverton Wyoming
that's how you start you know you don't
go easy you performing them before they
make you go to Wyoming and [__] some
[__] Cowboys house to do comedy so
anyways you're in the dumpster I'm in
the [__] thumbs okay and the next
thing you know I call [__] Rico and I
go Rico come get me and he goes where I
go I'm in this fluffle restaurant go
outside you know give me 20 min like
that synchronize because once I pop out
of the dumpster you gotta go I gotta run
right to the [__] car
you know I synchronize I pop out of the
dumpster and he's two blocks away he's
six foot six 350 pounds and he's waving
a tree and I see the cops by them cuz
they know so I look at him I go [__]
this I go back in the dumpster now I got
a stick there till it gets dark
oh I got a comedy show at the comedy
underground the Seattle I'm waiting in
the [__] dumpster for it to get dark
finally
this comes it's 8 o'clock I got no
change to make the phone call I got like
a 20 and a 10 in my pocket uh-huh I can
house a dumpster I scraped myself or I
take the lettuce off you know think I'm
ready to go I go into the restaurant I
ask to wash my hands
I walk up the [__] corner and there's
a movie theater there the first movie
these a man doesn't want to see Pulp
Fiction and not okay 95 okay the movie
theater so I know where I am the [__]
cops behind behind the bushes at the
[__] movie theater
you have no idea waiting for home they
were all over the place still waiting
some of the arresting me put me and
Young and drop the [__] charges oh I
stopped that told me how many times I
got arrested in cialis I proposed it
wouldn't come to Seattle never [__]
never that's [__] Remington in
Bremerton Washington is the lowest point
in United States that's why they have
all the submarines there oh so that's
why when the seventeen these umbrellas
only goes right into the [__] bottom
of the ocean they see Jacques Cousteau
they see [__] Jimmy Hoffa it's in
museum a deck down there but that
metaphysical that water and [__] [__]
me up I can't get the rest another time
me and her got into a [__] argument
in front of her building okay okay we
got into [__] 22 arguments you should
tell the neighbors if we get into an
argument call the police that he's kind
of scary we would just be yelling at
each other in the cops are come one time
again till now going right through a
computer an old computer has an electric
bill I threw the old computer off the
second floor she had broken stuff in
mine the [__] cops come I got a
running hi I ran into a pool and jumped
into the pool and the pig likes James
Bond cops were everywhere
yes they did yes I did he tops for
everyone on the [__] beach going back
and forth and I would pop out of the
pool like this blow and go right back
into [__] pools that time didn't find
me but the best drinking in the straw
oh yeah I didn't have a thought I was on
the move her and I maybe this is what
this is all more food this is one of
those love affairs that you always I put
sugar in my gas tank no you know that I
put sugar in her [__] gas tank how
much we were at war this was a
relationship that went on for 18 months
that was rotten wood friends today out
of some [__] something she left my
clothes on fire
so I [__] put sugar in that gas tank
she was driving a little [__]
cheating that mother [__] did I put
sugar in it and then I put saran wrap on
it cuz saran wrap is the double-check
when you put saran wrap in some of these
gas tank what happens to them this is
why a lot of this is gangsta [__] this
is what I learned in Colorado when you
want to shoot some bodies that you make
that car turn off you don't do this so
that you take saran wrap you roll in a
[__] ball you put in a gas tank when
the engine gets hot the saran wrap
expands and it covers the gas how do the
gap goes into the cost of your father
[__] cost loss so every time your car
gets hot like when I mean hot every time
you're in the car for 10 minutes on me
saran wrap expand and it goes around the
fuel injector at that time this is what
the gangsters taught me in Colorado the
hunters this is how they shot people
this is how crazy with it you never
shoot out a tie and all that [__] you
want it to look like it they'll never
figure out I don't know and even if you
take the car to any other mechanics
where you go to don't never figure it
out they have to take the gas tank out
drain the gas tank and there will be the
little [__] container of saran wrap
she'sa for you [__] I don't
know now you know the church or what's
happening now dropping [__] knowledge
on you somebody's buck to you you know
how to get him on top of the hill
[__] canoe room child runs and stop
the mechanic [__] that Jason's tram and
his bull he's [__] movie that movie's
on the other night the mechanic wasn't
about explosives it was about killing
people in a different way that's why
when they I knew they were going to do
that I knew they were going to take that
movie and turn into explosive mm oh the
mechanic was beautiful because he was 51
years old he can't go hand-to-hand
combat with you he's not international
he would kill you in a different way
like the piece he would look at your
records him you had a heart problem he
would wait and shoot at you so the
bullet will hit your leg and you had a
run something to make you run that's
what his plan was in the mechanic not to
blow [__] white people up with bombs
that's not the [__] thing of any
idiot can do that any idiot could do
that so but the best one ever
was her and I would not want to see each
other and I took
ecstasy and Josh wolf House Josh wolf
had one-hitter access to the left and he
goes it's Monday morning look I got to
the left I go or what he's not doing it
was nothing
give me that [__] back the same way
you see me to [__] in the peanut brittle
at 7:01 I inhaled that [__] hit
ecstasy right I forget about I go meet a
bunch of comedian again and wanita he
was right that's how I roll right I go
down the Swan ease the ball at the time
on Coppola comedy underground okay and
when hanging out that at two o'clock she
pages me she's really doing come over
and eat my ass please take a dynamite in
my ass or what LM way all right
[__] go over there I'm there three
five minutes we're in the woods
just hang swap and spitting also hear
boom boom boom boom boom boom cuz the
neighbors call the costumers she's
police so I got no shirt I'm about to
get into my sexy mode you know haha I
got my shirt off like Engelbert
Humperdinck before he makes the move the
cops come and I go into the bed but my
gut is kind of big at the time so every
time I breathe the whole bed goes up and
down
I don't match it they're over there
laughing their asses off I mean I was
try the hide in the hamper I'm a great
hider when the cops show up
I even jump out the back window so that
I get out of the car I forgot I took the
ecstasy okay so I took the exes II like
it uh maybe 9:00 the morning makeup at
12:00 or 1:00 o'clock it hit me but it
hit me they took me out of her apartment
with no shirt on and put those rubber
things around my hand okay so here I am
cops Lyla Seattle they're talking Devin
and I'm hot decide handcuffed with that
rubber [__] with no shirt on like
[__] yahoo out of conscious I'm just
looking around the [__] place they
put me in the police club I get to the
[__] Seattle I get into the south and
that's when the access key starts
kicking but there's no music music in
the cell is the holding tank I'm [__]
in them starting to sweat I want to be
chatty with the other [__] criminals
they don't want to chat with me finally
they call me over to go to fingerprint
yes I'm fingerprinting bro I'm talking
to the [__] I'm giggling ah I'm
touching his bag he's like this that
[__] ecstasy hit me - God knows big
neither Sun like holy [__] I went out
with more the only idiots ever that have
gone
in jail and I hit a [__] ecstasy and
you were hiding under a bed in the bed
man I would hide under the bed and the
bed was going up and [__] down in
between the stuff is this like the kind
of a relationship where you have these
blowouts
but then in the cleaning be having that
did it be great in between these yes
yeah but every couple months you even
hit it with every couple months every
weekend and reduction every week there
was drama in that [__] because she was
crazy
yeah she's [__] crazy and you're
crazy and in this that's what happens
when you have two [__] are the
crazy it's Monday ly [__] sky ass
Alicia Michael's taking pictures Felicia
Michael should have been born a jack you
know that man
I never seen nobody who takes more
[__] pictures Thanks I guarantee you
take pictures when you're sucking dick
with one hand taking pictures of guys
stomach oh this is look nice by the
[__] coffee table
un-fuckin'-believable science
[__] it's a beaut it's going to
be a great week Thursday I'm going to
Minneapolis I'll be at the house of rig
Bronson's house of comedy get your
[__] tickets now next week me Duncan
Trussell are going to Madison Wisconsin
to champs or some [__] like that so if
you live in Madison coming to [__] out
and this Friday we're going to Milwaukee
Wisconsin I got to get a hold of my man
up there the [__] kick boxing coach
so we'll be up there brown paper tickets
testicle Testaments is still wrong you
know I heard it still [__] kicking
ass I haven't looked lately I've been
spacing it out you know using the Beast
is on the [__] charts tomorrow we're
supposed to do an acupuncture thing but
she called we might have to do it at
your house she would do that and punch
at your house which will be perfect and
then we'll walk to the thing and taste
some [__] pictures Lee what do you
got going on [__] not much I want
to talk about son but who is hooking up
clone one didn't own the corn Winston
Timmy Marblehead the driver when we
robbed Michael when we robbed the
jewelry store September 15th 1982 he's
gonna be calling on Wednesday because he
called for the first episode we never
really had it and we were we didn't know
what the [__] were doing
yeah so that's how it turns the [__] out
you know I'm saying so yeah I wanted to
say I was listening and when I'm when
you're talking to me I'm listening
also trying to pay attention to level
and he said some nice things like how it
helped doubt it I really appreciate it
but I want people to know that you
probably in it sounds a little dramatic
but you probably saved my life you know
in a way there's when we first started
meeting I was working a job that's this
job for about two years and I was good
to have a job but I was I was depressed
I didn't like it and to be honest with
you my least and my partner was up /
January and if we had been working
together I'd be back in Boston working
on a crappy TV station so you've said
some really nice things to me the past
couple days and I want to say like if I
hadn't been doing this stuff I'd be back
in Boston doing cracking TV or some of
those but it's great to be doing this
with you I'm glad people like it and it
says this is the chance and Felicia took
a chance
I went to Felicia two years ago I said
hey honey we're gonna do a podcast in a
while oh no what the [__] don't you
[__] out window by Bob haha I'm a
[__] scumbag and you're a scumbag and
Felicia just come back because we
convince people to - [__] you know we
have a good time doing it you know I
convinced Alisha to do being the Beast
you know she convinces make it villain
[__] then you convinced me to do this so
we all saved each other's lives and
that's what it's all about that's why
we're all in the [__] room you know
we took the chance man
this isn't cool you know when you come
to LA as we should know is it people
come up too much because you show oh my
god let's pitch it at PBS and you go
down and you pitch your Fox so you
picture whatever and they tell you no
come back with a star normally nothing
all we needed for this was two
turntables in a mic that's it that's
[__] it man then we got on them we do
for you know a lot of great things that
happens with Felicia she just booked
another Nickelodeon or mission to to
stand up things and she calls in some
sense and I could hear the excitement of
her voice but to me I know these things
are going to happen because you're
putting effort in nobody's paying us for
this we got up to five minutes not a
moment
into this [__] we do it to them I do it
to these people so when I go on Twitter
I tumble wash their [__] [__] it's
[__] Monday [__] they
understand what we're coming from this
is a combination that's deadly you know
and uh we took a chance and when I
[__] the best podcasters in the world
which is not the best podcast but we all
know that's what comes out of our heart
and that's the most important thing to
me so we I thank you I think my partner
Felicia I thank Lee every [__] day
people going online lately saying [__]
about Lee the Cox Lucky's a Jew
plot them that's the beauty about
[__] being a Jew they're gonna keep
[__] talking we're all [__] Jews
it's like my man's war movie said if you
get did you get your [__] wake-up call
if you shake your family tree a [__]
will fall out that's it this movie who
the [__] we are
let's do it it's Monday it's a beautiful
[__] week we are great [__] ahead of
us tomorrow season premiere Suns a
[__] anarchy I'll be pop you
know what I don't even know what I'm
gonna do I got to do some drugs that's
exotic it has something like that I got
our I ate the peanut brittle I got the
[__] vape okay
what else can I do I mean what else can
we do that you know ride a motorcycle
around town who means yes what [__]
motorcycle I'm only like a days are
robo-dog all right those out of came the
helmet to get fit this [__] big guys
I don't know where they get a helmet for
Ron Perlman I'm what mama one of the big
weeds in your back I should go get a
[__] motorcycle I'm gonna let me
[__] intense
let's get [__] what else we got
for this week not much but I want for
people because we had that guy right in
and a finding worked hard in his uh I
mean I would have never had I heard
about you on the Rogan podcast and I
would never imagined like I wrote you
just I wrote I seems like midnight or
something I said hey I want to do
something with comedian and a year and a
half later we did a TV documentary we're
doing this it's good so don't ever sing
you can't do it or or just give it a try
and do it gasps who gives up [__] don't
let nobody tell you know if you want to
do something you believe is the most
important is your [__] believe and
that's it have a great [__] week oil
being the Beast talk cat shows up this
week also if you want to support us with
shirts go tube using the Beast podcast
calm if you want to support me with
shirts girls enjoy covered ears net we
also got based on there we got [__]
going on I don't know what else to tell
you it's a month it's the [__] church
or what's happening I hope you got
something out of this today don't pull a
bitch's hair when she rips up each what
made me do
let's put some music on the way up we
got the doors riders on the storm and it
should be playing how do we you're
nothing
oh [__] have a good day god bless you
wash your [__] [__] get out their
most important things [__] justify
your existence [__] stay black
Joe Biden
[Music]
riders on the storm